the public exposure of a very secretive
operation the U.S justice department
announcing International action against
the bitslato cryptocurrency exchange its
Russian head Anatoly Lego dimov arrested
by FBI agents in an early morning raid
in Miami today's law enforcement actions
put all of those who seek to exploit the
cryptocurrency ecosystem on notice
that the Department of Justice will use
every tool working along with our
partners every tool that we have to
attack the criminal use of the dark net
and cryptocurrency
the bits later website is predictably
down a message earlier said it had been
seized by international law enforcement
action based in Hong Kong Run by a
Russian U.S treasury Department says it
laundered hundreds of millions of
dollars and became a key point for
criminality on the dark web the treasury
Department says that makes it something
that could be used to help Russia's war
in Ukraine at a time when Russia's
waging a brutal and unjustified war in
Ukraine and as it seeks to circumvent
sanctions and governance controls to
fill its coffers and sustain its
violence
we will not tolerate criminals
Enterprises that enrich Russia's
malicious interests
I sing online scams and laundering
ransomware cash it isn't ruling out
further charges and claims today's
action shuts down a busy corner of the
criminal ecosystem Alan Fisher Al
Jazeera Washington